Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number
and that number is 2192. David P.
I don't remember when it was yesterday or the day
before. I pointed out that when someone said less,
it's actually fewer. And now I'm getting attacked
as an intellectual douche. Listen to this.
Speaker 2: And just listen to your show today.
And you, like, make fun of someone for saying
lesser instead of fewer or less instead of fewer.
And I just thought that's kind of below you know,
there's a lot of really intelligent people
out there who don't know that that's how
you're supposed to use the word. Myself
included. I'm I am a very smart, educated,
high IQ person. I believe you didn't know
that. So I just think it's kind of a silly
thing to make someone make fun of someone
for. And it just makes you seem like you're
being a little bit of an intellectual douche.
Speaker 1: Okay, So listen, this is actually
something that there's a backstory to this. I
used to get very confused with less and fewer,
and just a few years ago I was getting crushed
for it in the comments. And then now it's sort
of like a joke that I pointed out when other
people do it. Not being an intellectual douche,
not being condescending, very smart people mix
that up all the time. I speak English as a second
language. It has to be explained to me in explicit
detail. Let's not take everything personally,
and it really sounds like this guy saying I see
myself as incredibly smart, like my IQ is really,
really high and I didn't know that. So therefore
it must not be important. You must be making fun
of people. Let's all relax, okay? It's fine. It's
fine. If you were less than okay. Not a big deal.
We have a great bonus show for you
today. A truck crash near the White House
and a Nazi flag was reportedly found outside
of the truck, which was in the truck. And it
is again raising questions about what is going
on here. Secondly, Ireland is going to start
requiring cancer warnings and calorie counts on
alcoholic, alcoholic beverages. This is something
many in the U.S. have been advocating for, saying,
listen, we put a lot of this stuff on Cigarets,
we should put it on alcohol as well. We do
have surgeon general's warnings on alcohol
about pregnant women, but some people want to
see more and Ireland is doing more. We will
discuss. And lastly, Ron DeSantis has created a
police program to lure officers to work as police
in Florida who have violent records in their
pasts. Why is this being done? Does it make
any sense? Is it a good idea? We will deal with
all of those questions and more when producer
Pat joins me on today's bonus show. Get instant
access to the bonus show by signing up at join
Pacman dot com. It's cheap quick and the most
direct and important way to support our program
and remember that if you would like you can get
on my newsletter at David Packman dot com and
Monday morning you'll get an email telling you
how to sign up for membership at a dramatically
discounted rate. That's Monday Memorial Day.
Just get on my newsletter at David Mark McMahon.